if you could master one of the four  bases of sex but you'd have to be below  average at every other base which one  would you choose i feel like honestly  this is controversial but first base you  don't if you're a bad kisser you can't  get anywhere and then you can kiss a  dick the way you kiss a mouth and i when  i think of bad k it's like they're i've  had bad kissers in my life and it's like  it it's such a deal breaker you can't  get horny there there's always like a  breath situation a teeth situation  they're making their lips really tight  yeah no my boyfriend has a joke will  come in with like a tight mouth and i'm  like even as a joke i don't like  butthole mouth like i'm like  juice him up but he's got juicy lips